this week we're asking you the listener
to go fill out a survey for our
advertisers it will help us get the best
ads for our listeners so more of stuff
that appeals to you and less of stuff
that you really really want to
fast-forward through I will also be
reading these results so I do want to
know if you're working in Sciences if
you're listening in the car on the train
in the gym in the lab you get it so
please go to paws survey comm slash
science mag that's science - mag this
time and take a quick anonymous survey
that will help us get to know you a
little better plus once you've completed
the survey you can choose to enter for a
chance to win a $100 Amazon gift card
terms and conditions apply
again that's pod survey comm slash
science mag SC ience - maj thank you for
your help
welcome to the science podcast for a
February 22nd 2019 I'm Sara Krusty in
this week's show I talk with Lizzie Wade
about monitoring of buildings health in
real time
consensus tell us if a building is
structurally sound after an earthquake
and Megan Cantwell talks to Svetlana but
soon about a new estimate for the height
of the Tibetan Plateau 40 million years
ago it turns out it was about 1500
meters shorter than they thought what
does it mean that researchers were wrong
about its height and what else might we
need to recalculate now we have Lizzie
Wade a contributing correspondent for
science she writes this week about
monitoring the structural integrity of
buildings kind of in real-time taking a
look at how they're dealing with
vibrations and how they fared after an
earthquake hi Lizzie hi Sarah I wanted
to start with you know the fact that you
live in Mexico City and there was a
really big earthquake there recently and
this is something that's very important
to say people who live next to a
building that collapsed they want to
know did my building just make it
through by the skin of its teeth or is
it okay now and you visited a school
that did not make it through can you
talk about what that was like sure yeah
I think people who aren't haven't been
in an earthquake where buildings have
collapsed don't really know how much the
uncertainty can weigh on you afterwards
I visited a school in the state of
Morelos in Mexico which is very close to
the epicenter of the earthquake that
happened on September 19 2017 which was
the last really big one that we had here
in Mexico most of the school is one
story buildings but there's one that's a
two storey building kind of a classic
big staircase leading up to the second
floor landing that lets you into various
classrooms on the second floor and
during the earthquake one of the columns
holding up that landing cracked and the
landing tipped over pretty precariously
and all the kids were inside it was very
scary and everyone got out ok in the
building was still stable enough to be
repaired it repaired the column and
repaired the landing and it was then
fine but the principal told me that the
kids were scared for months to go back
up to those
in floor classrooms right and know that
there are earthquake proofing techniques
that can go into building but those
aren't always available they're not
always enforced what we're gonna talk
about today is monitoring your buildings
health using some kind of sensor what
what would this sensor be listening for
or looking for the basis of these
sensors are accelerometers which
basically measure the movement of a
point in three-dimensional space over
time I'm waving my phone around right
now and my phone knows it exactly yeah
so accelerometers are in lots of things
and they're the basis of national
seismic networks that countries deploy
around their seismically active regions
to measure the magnitude of earthquakes
and things like that they're also in
your phone in your car and video game
controllers accelerometers have gone
through this huge revolution recently
previously to get a really sensitive
accelerometer you needed to spend a lot
of money yeah and now you can get really
really affordable accelerometers that
are quite quite sensitive I was
surprised to learn that a very fancy I
guess you would say very expensive
skyscrapers do already have sensors on
them that detect shakes or wind or that
kind of thing yeah for a long time I
think in places like California and
Japan especially during construction of
skyscrapers and bridges they put in
these expensive accelerometers and
sensor networks and basically what the
accelerometers are doing is measuring
continuously the vibration of buildings
buildings can vibrate from a lot of
things I can graduate from a big
earthquake if congr I break from a
garbage truck driving by so if you can
measure the continuous vibration of a
building you can know something about
its properties and then kind of judge
how those properties may have changed
after a big earthquake right well let's
talk a little bit about the kind of
analysis that you need to do so say you
have a sensor we're not talking about
the big fancy skyscrapers anymore we're
just talking about a sensor in your
school is it measuring all the time what
the you know any vibrations hitting it
and adding up those up through time or
is it just saying oh something's changed
about the building and you mean you may
need to do an inspection yeah it's more
the second one although it does measure
it measures all vibrations continuously
which is also newly possible thanks to
cloud compute
how cheap processing power and data
storage has become recently because
obviously if you're measuring every
second of a building's vibration you
need somewhere to put that data it also
was a big challenge so it measures the
vibrations continuously and that can
tell you things like the resonant
frequency of the building but what the
affordable networks really focus on
because this is one of the best defined
parameters in terms of like translating
it to what it means in the real world is
a thing called inner story drift which
is basically how much the different
levels different floors of a building
jerk out of alignment with a big shaking
event like an earthquake I mean it could
happen theoretically with any kind of
shaking event but the ones that we're
worried about are bigger right do you
mean with respect to each other during
the event or once the event is over how
far out of alignment they are I think it
can be either although I'm not totally
sure I think it's like sort of how far
they've jerked out of alignment and then
sometimes I imagine they can come back
into alignment but knowing that it
passes threshold every building has a
threshold beyond which the potential for
damage becomes really high it's
important to know even if the building
looks fine and if you took my measuring
stick and like measured how far out of
alignment the floors are after the
shaking stopped it could still have
passed the threshold during the shaking
and said you know so that's important to
know you did mention that there is some
kind of value that you want to compare
against but that is a bit of a tricky
part for this like where do the data
come from that tell you this is a
healthy building this is the threshold
now this is a dangerous or sick building
yeah you talked a little bit about where
that data comes from ideally you would
do it based on structural models of
individual buildings my apartment
building if I got one of these really
expensive sensors installed we'd go to
public records or go to the architect of
my building and get the exact blueprints
and make a commuter paddle based on my
building and then that would be a pretty
stable and and firm comparison to like
the real world that is really expensive
and sort of the point of this technology
and the reason you know it can be going
in public schools in Morales Mexico is
that it's supposed to be cheap so what
these companies are doing and there's a
commune xqo that I visited
there's another company in Taiwan and
there are others throughout the world
they basically use standard blueprints
for various very typical building
designs throughout the years so the
school and Marella's for example like
was a really classic two-story school
design like these things are all over
Mexico they felt pretty confident the
company called Brielle felt pretty
confident that with the blueprints that
they had they would have a good idea of
how this building would move to really
like have more certainty you do it based
on individualized blueprint of that
building okay back to the school for a
second there was a discussion or there
was a mention in your story that they
were going to have an go no-go light so
it would reassure the students but also
it's basically letting you know the
health of your building whenever you
walk by it yeah so there's a stoplight
now it's like it's thin cylindrical tube
with a green orange and red light like a
traffic light and it is normally off
although every day in the morning it
takes through the lights if everything
is working smoothly that's sort of the
sign that that it's okay and then after
an earthquake what will happen is if the
building has not passed the threshold of
interest or a drift another signs of
damage the green light will go on for
five minutes and that will say okay this
building's very very very likely safe to
return to and then if there is some
damage detected either the orange light
or the red light will go on and red is
like definitely damaged do not go back
in and oranges probably damaged may be
damaged still don't go back in that's
because there's there's always going to
be some uncertainty inherent in these
systems although you know there is also
uncertainty in here in the expection set
where I got engineers do one of the
ideas is that if you had sort of a
critical mass of these stop lights and
sensors in the chaotic hours after a big
earthquake the engineers who go around
and inspect buildings would have some
guidance it's like ok gosh red lights do
not go into this building this is really
important that we see orange light come
here right now
we're not sure green light we can wait a
little while to see if they're okay
that's a really big priority especially
for the companies who are trying to
deploy this I have here on my question
list can this give you a warning
did you have advance notice
you can run out the sensors that I'm
talking about here don't give you
earthquake early warning but actually
something that's not in my story is that
many of these companies also work on
earthquake early warning because the
kind of sensors you need to detect these
very early signs of shaking are also
plummeting and cost and can be deployed
in large numbers just sounds like
there's companies already selling these
products figuring out how to install
them in schools what further refinements
what's next up to the science there's
other things you can measure in a
building other than inner story drift
like I mentioned resonant frequency
resident frequency the classic example
is a tuning fork you hit it and it
always resonates at the same pitch you
know because that's its resonant
frequency everything has resonant
frequencies including buildings you can
see with these sensors sort of changes
over time in resident frequency both
before and after an earthquake but also
buildings that have been monitored for a
long time seem to just randomly change
there is no frequency figuring out how
that corresponds or doesn't to actual
damage in a building that's not your
question and potentially interesting
like you can get a lot of information
out of these sensors scientists don't
actually know what to do with all of it
yeah so that's kind of interesting and
also in the future if you had even
better sensors more of them ones that
were more tailored to individual
buildings it might even be able to tell
you eventually if not just crude red
green light the economy kind of thing it
might be able to tell you this is where
the damage is likely in your building
which would it be even more guidance for
civil engineers that would take a lot
more data like it would have to be
deployed in a massive scale with massive
investment but that's something that
scientists could theoretically do in the
future
Wow really interesting Lizzy and I just
have to mention that and when I read
inter storey drift I thought of all the
writers who work here I also think about
that know what a great what a great
metaphor okay Lizzy thank you so much
thank you Lizzy wade is a contributing
correspondent for science you can find a
link to her story at science Magdeburg
slash podcast stay tuned for Megan cam
wells interview with Svetlana but soon
about measuring the height of the
Tibetan Plateau 40 million years ago
stay tuned for Megan cam wells interview
with Svetlana but soon about measuring
the height of the Tibetan Plateau 40
million years ago the Tibetan Plateau is
a vastly elevated area in Central and
East Asia with an average elevation of
4500 meters this mountainous region has
some mystery surrounding it though
specifically when did it reach its
towering height I'm Megan camel and I'm
with Svetlana Watson to talk about how
they determined just how high the
Tibetan Plateau was over 40 million
years ago hi Svetlana how are you hey
I'm good first could you talk a little
bit about the theory behind how the
Tibetan Plateau initially formed the
Tibetan Plateau was from during the
collision between Indian Asia blades
about 55 million years ago the place
came together and they collided and the
Pledger
started to uplift but actual timing of
our lift is unknown there are still a
lot of discussion on their hate of the
Tibetan Plateau your field of research
is called paleo altimetry and that's the
study of past elevation of land surfaces
like mountains and it's pretty hard to
quantify but your team did arrive at an
estimate of how high the Tibetan Plateau
was 40 million years ago during the
Eocene could you talk a little bit about
your methods for how you determine this
estimate so we go to mountains we
measure carbonates and we use
theoretically established relationship
between elevation and oxygen isotopes in
precipitation and can guess what was
follow elevation but in our approach we
suggest to do another method we suggest
using climate models because oxygen in
precipitation is influenced not only by
elevation itself but also by
paleoclimate and with a general
circulation model called LM desert it's
a French model and it
can produce a global climate and
numerical climate model we have access
to both Tupelo elevation and to below
climate just looking at the isotopes
within these carbonates isn't going to
tell you what the elevation was because
there's other factors in play like the
climate that you have to take a new
account without knowledge about
paleoclimate without running a special
climate models we actually can
misinterpret this records so that's why
we're suggesting running in climate
models so how do you know what the
climate was like this far in the past
it's difficult to know we can try to
apply several boundary conditions for
example we know that concentration of
greenhouse gases in the Eocene was
different from today we also know that
other geography in the EU scene was
different for example we had this pirata
TC to the north of Tibetan Plateau that
has a potential influence on climate in
the region so we applied these boundary
conditions and we ran a global general
circulation model that could predict
climate based on those boundary
conditions and a cool thing in our model
that we have implementation of stable
oxygen isotopes directly so we simulate
in a model stable oxygen isotopes
together with a climate change so we
have boats we have stable oxygen
isotopes and planet how does the Tibetan
Plateau
currently impact the climate around the
area it's a main driving for the monsoon
over Asia and India it also impacts
global climate because it's have a huge
impact on global atmospheric circulation
when the plateau is not that high it's
possible that the monsoon circulation is
different from today so that's why it's
so important to know the innovation
based on taking into account the climate
during the Eocene what was your team's
estimate for how high the Tibetan
Plateau was 40 million years ago it was
about three kilometers high so today
it's about four and a half kilometers
high these contradicts previous studies
which concluded that probably in the
ears in Tibet worse at the
same innovation as today what kind of
impact would that have had on the
climate in general circulation model
it's kind of the same so we have a
monsoon we able to simulate years in
monsoon in the region and we also have
westerlies West releases means that
coming from west through northern part
of the tibetan plateau and central asia
we do simulate this global climate
features but precipitation amount itself
was different and it was also warmer
because of these greenhouse gases
concentration in the atmosphere it's
warmer climate with no convection
different amount precipitation in the
south and part it was more likely more
precipitation but to the northern part
of Tibetan Plateau and Central Asia it
was drier and that difference in climate
probably changes the types of flora and
fauna that could survive in the areas
and what's interesting is that fossil
evidence in the past has supported a
lower Tibetan Plateau during the Eocene
our interpretation of stable oxygen
isotope its data are really supported by
paleo botanic evidences if the Tibetan
Plateau was not at its current height 40
million years ago that must mean there
was some kind of uplift event in between
40 million years ago and now does your
study say anything about when the
additional uplift event could have
occurred in what might have caused it
with our study we can't tell what exact
reason this on occasion it's a drop of
Jordan amesys right lots of people have
to work together to solve that exactly
I'm curious what the uncertainties and
limitations share modeling approach are
we have uncertainties linked with our
modeling of course because we put into a
model several boundary conditions for
example estimation of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere it's we've been best
for today estimation of co2 another
uncertainty lean-to is using using
paleogeography based on other methods
such as palo magnetic
studies we could tell
we are was position of India we are was
a parrot ATC at that time so we used the
best for presently existing
paleogeography and put it into a model
but we are aware that it could be that
paleogeography was different for the
Eocene there's so many other
reconstructions that have to be refined
in order to get a good Paleo re-estimate
so since you determined that you kind of
need to have other factors taken into
account in order to determine the
elevation how do you think this will
change how things are studied within
your field I'm pretty sure that the
results of our research would have quite
an important impact on diverse
communities of Jo scientists this method
could be applied in any region of the
world let's say in the Andes Cascadia
soar the elves second we have shown that
the elevation of the Tibet was probably
not that high in the Eocene this is
important for example for Georgian
Ambika community for understanding the
timing of dynamical events over the
region svetlana bot xun is a
postdoctoral researcher at the Tubingen
university in germany she also conducted
this research in the laboratory of
climate and environment in Paris France
you can find a link to her research at
science mag podcasts and that concludes
this edition of the science podcast if
you have any comments or suggestions for
the show write to us at science podcast
at AAA s o RG ya and please do let me
know where you listen to the podcast I'm
pretty sure the survey isn't actually
gonna ask that question so write in to
us and tell us where you're listening
the Atlantic and scribe to the show
anywhere you get your podcasts or you
can listen on the science website let
science max last podcast to place an ad
on the podcast contact mid-roll comm the
show was produced by Sarah crusty and
Megan Cantwell and edited by Potter G
Geoffrey cook composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and its
publisher triple-a s thanks for joining
us